في منطقه يشهد تاريخها بالصمود امام
الكوارث الطبيعيه كان زلزال يان الصينيه
احد اكثرها عنفا خلال السنوات الاخيره
حينما تسبب في طمس معالم قريه كامله في
اقل من دقيقه فما القصه في صبيحه العشرين
من شهر ابريل للعام 2013 ضرب زلزال كبير
جنوب غرب الصين شعر به نحو مليوني شخص
انتشرت الفوضى في مقاطعه
المجاوره وبدا الناس يهرعون من المباني
الى الطرقات في محاولات للنجاه
خلال الزلزال الذي استمر دقيقه انهارت
جميع المباني في قريه لونجمان وتضرر ما
يقرب من عشره الاف منزل في انحاء محافظه
لوشان كما قطعت الطرق وانقطعت امدادات
المياه والكهرباء وخدمات الاتصالات في
غضون ساعات قليله حددت هيئه المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكي قوته عند سته فاصله
سته درجات وقام مركز شبكات زلزال الصين
بقياسها عند سبع درجات فيما رصد مركز
الزلزال في منطقه لوشان في مدينه يان التي
تعد موطنا للباندا العملاقه الشهيره في
البلاد
بتوجيه من السلطات تدفق الالاف من عمال
الطوارئ والعساكر الى المناطق المتضرره
واوقفت الرحلات في مطار تشينغو لفتره
وجيزه كما علقت عمليات نقل السكك الحديديه
عاليه السرعه بحلول الليل كانت تجمعات من
الخيام تنتشر على طول الارصفه وفي الحدائق
ومحطات الحافلات فيما ازعجت الهزات
الارتداديه التي استمرت لنحو اربع وعشرين
ساعه سكان المنطقه المنكوبه امتدت اثار
الزلزال لتشمل 111 مقاطعه في 18 محافظه
وتسبب في تدمير او انهيار اكثر من 200
وخمسين الف منزل
تسببت الكارثه بمقتل 192 شخصا فيما تم
الابلاغ عن 23 اخرين في عداد المفقودين
واكثر من 11 الف مصاب في كارثه اعتبرت من
الاكثر عنفا بعد زلزال سيشوان للعام 2008
[موسيقى]